[Music]
ariana grande dropped I'm gonna say
ferocious video for her new song
boyfriend and we've got everything you
need to know first of all the video
stars Ariana and social houses
Mikey foster whose characters are in a
complex relationship
[Music]
like so many people out there they
aren't an official couple but they don't
want each other dating other people we
literally see Ariana dreaming about
physically attacking women and of course
Mikey does the same but with men
[Music]
yeah he literally just ripped that other
dudes heart out ariana took to Twitter
to explain what it all means
quote I feel like the song captures a
common theme in the lives of so many
people I know people want to feel loved
but don't want to define their
relationship and have trouble fully
committing or trusting or allowing
themselves to fully love someone even
though they want to okay and that's not
all she also said quote we wanted to
make something uplifting that captures
that feeling of being afraid to take the
leap and trust being afraid of being
hurt or feeling like you won't be enough
for that person but also how it feels to
have a crippling crush on someone
[Music]
I just want to know who Arianna is
crushing on right now the video was
directed by Hannah Lux Davis who has
worked with re a ton I'm so grateful for
her because I get to do what I love to
do and she's grateful for me cuz I get
to execute what she loves to do and the
new video isn't the only exciting thing
going on Ferrari right now she also just
made what seems to be a cameo on Jim
Gary's Showtime show kidding she posted
this pic of the pair writing in part
quote I've been staring at my screen and
no words do this moment justice thankful
for the most special experience of my
life and nothing is crazier than getting
to work with and spend time with someone
whom you've idolized and adored since
before you could speak cannot wait to
see that but back to the boyfriend video
you are my girlfriend
you see nobody I can guarantee that so
what was your favorite part let me know
and for all the latest on Ariana and
your other favorite celebs keep it
locked to all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krauss and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]